Hello everybody!
I think the chat is a little delayed.
But turtles, thank you for the akasuba.
Thank you.
I said in the chat, I was like, no!
No, akasuba, no!
If you notice something different about me, I am not an
angel when I have a halo.
I have Shiroko.
Look at her.
She's voiced by Ogura Yui Maiseu Oshi.
I'm here for Blue Archive.
I'm here.
Where are the horns?
Is she not cool?
It doesn't have horns?
Who?
Okay, there's actually a lot of characters that have horns
in Blue Archive.
Oh gosh.
This is going to turn into a stream about me wanting to talk
about Blue Archive, I think,
than playing Majang, maybe.
I'm actually quite nervous because...
I was like, oh my god.
I'm so nervous.
What if I just like, I don't know, because I get really
embarrassed about like, I don't know.
I don't know.
I just get embarrassed.
I was like, it's like learning something like this.
What if I don't get it and people think I'm so dumb?
Because this is actually not my first time trying to learn
Majong.
I've tried to learn before in the past, but I, um, I, I, I
just didn't get it at all.
It's okay, we already think that.
Yippee!
It's okay if you don't, plenty of streamers don't.
Okay, will you guys help me?
Will you guys help me?
It takes a bit before it clicks.
I've had friends try to teach me.
I've tried to learn through Majang Soul.
I've tried learning from...
Maybe I'm not like applying myself as much as I should, you
know.
of like maybe i'm just kind of like whatever just click
click block set block something happen i don't know i know
nothing about blue archive normajang well today you might
learn about both at least blue archive i can i can i can
teach you at least about blue archive which look at these
girls oh my gosh they're so cute Right?
That's Shiroko.
She's so cute.
I love... She's kind of like Kudere, but she's also like
silly.
Which is what I really like about her.
Because she's got like a cool personality.
Thank you!
Gotcha puns.
No, gotcha puns.
Um...
As a Majan player, anyone who tells you they know how to
play is lying.
That makes me feel a little better.
Yeah, Shiroko is goofy as hell.
She's so goofy.
she's so she's so silly silly kudere is peak yes right i
think it's like why i love um why i love free run so much
andregos thank you for the 10 gifted thank you number one
beginner rule don't call tiles except to win what if i know
their phone number and what if i'm like looking for a little
bit of a booty call then can i call them what if they tell
me what if they tell me what if they're to get and I'm just
trying to like you know show that I have interest non gotcha
funds thank you yeah that's acceptable okay an official
mahjong soul anime came out today wait that came out today
because I saw I saw that that existed But it was today?
That's so funny.
I learned from Saki, so this should be fine.
I didn't finish Saki, but what I learned from Saki is that
panties are overrated.
Nobody in that show wears them.
I mean, asking anyone for a booty call.
It's a boo, get it?
Boo, booty call.
Aru, my beloved.
This is Aru right here.
She looks very cool and very lovely.
like mysterious and not mysterious maybe like mature mature
another m word that i was saying she looks very mature and
very cool but she's actually also kind of a girl failure
this is hoshino she's the oji san um with a tragic past and
this is muzuki and she's just a little brat she's so cute
kind of look i'm being i'm being nice okay
Silly head empty out of my beloved Very girl failure She is
so kusogaki Yeah she is Mutsuki is very kusogaki She's very
cute Very very cute Sal I don't There's Oh I was gonna say
there's not a single character in Blue Archive that I
dislike But I don't think that's true actually Um There's
one girl in Blue Archive who, her voice, like, she's very
cute, but her voice just grates on me so bad.
So bad.
Oji, sound very cute.
Bashamine!
She's a girl!
How did you guys know?
Wait, is it not just me?
Oh my gosh.
No way.
No way!
Is it not just me?
I feel really validated right now.
Oh my gosh, I feel...
During the event, there was an event recently in Blue
Archive where like, they did like, what's the word?
What's the word?
Like a bathing suit.
They were like, it was a summer event.
They were on like bathing suits and stuff.
And I could barely touch the event because Shizuko was so...
Oh my gosh.
I would click the page and she would talk and I'd be like,
Ah!
Oh!
I'm like covering my ear.
I'm like, Oh, no, I feel so bad saying that because I'm sure
her Sayu is like super cute and super nice and everything.
She's just doing her best.
Oh, gosh.
And she's going so cute herself, you know?
Didn't know Blue Archive got a new student.
Who's the cute one on the bottom left?
Can we pull her yet?
Will her headpats, we'll give her headpats in the memorial
lobby.
Mutsuki?
Wait, can you see?
Okay, good.
I was making sure you could...
Okay.
Her voice is the best part.
It's definitely a charm point, I'm sure, for some.
But that event specifically made me be like, oh gosh.
Oh gosh.
Literally one of my favorite aspects about Shizuko is her
voice.
That's okay.
Like I said, it is a charm point for some people.
You know?
It's a charm.
And I like her recollection very much.
It's very cute.
She is really cute.
She's very cute.
Why are you upset?
Why are you upset, Jun?
Is it because I said she's a goban?
I didn't say she's a goban.
I didn't say it, though.
But as for my favorite Blue Archive characters, I really
like...
Hold on, let me just pull up my...
I've had to do this the other day, too.
Let's see.
Actually, did I do my daily stuff?
I don't know if I played before the before the reset or not
Time to do them now.
We will play mahjong Sorry, everybody.
I'm too busy talking about blue archive It's the only reason
I'm here So I play I play um, I don't play the Japanese blue
archive.
I play the English blue archive.
So um For now, my favorite characters.
I'm really excited, though, about the...
There's a battle in progress?
I did?
I had a battle in progress?
Wait.
Who?
Oh!
Oopsie.
I'm just gonna forfeit.
Quit mission.
Oopsie.
Isn't the EN Blue Archive getting the real gun character
soon?
They are!
BA is awful worst FPS I've ever played oh yes the um yeah
you know I get it where's the first person okay students my
baby girls are um Koharu Cherino this is not in any order
but Koharu and Cherino are like two of my top favorites.
I love Chenino a lot.
She's so dumb.
She's just so stupid.
I really love Toki.
I do like Hoshi no a lot too.
Of course I love Shiroko.
I want to try.
Actually, I do like Mutsuki, but she's like not one of my
top tops.
Also, isn't her ear supposed to be like pointy it doesn't
look as pointy here toky my beloved i actually have a
document of toky i got it at comic kit it's she's really
sexy in it i remember seeing i remember seeing it from the
line waiting to get in and um and uh i was like oh i have to
go there i have to i have to get that so because I wasn't
familiar with the artist but I went to Ayami's booth and
then I went to someone else maybe it was Pan Pan no Mimi or
Kaori but they were very close they were very close who's
the artist do you guys mind if I get the dojin?
Hold on.
Let me double check.
I should follow them.
Hold on.
I'm going to turn this down.
The music doesn't loop as like the music needs to be a
little bit longer.
Okay, hold on.
Let me get the dojin.
I'm really glad I knew where it was because I went through
some of my I went through some of my books recently.
So I was, I knew, I knew where it was.
Shino Kitsune.
Shiro Kitsune is the artist at Shiro-ro Kitsune.
So at Shiro-ro Kitsune.
So instead, their name is Shiro Kitsune, but their ad is at
Shiro-ro Kitsune.
And if you see the daki, it's so...
It's actually maybe...
It's actually maybe the softest daki makura I've ever owned.
Type it in the Chapman?
Oh, yeah, I can do that.
Give me one second.
At...
There you go.
It's probably the softest daki makura I've ever owned.
And Toki is just so...
She's so cute and so sexy on one side.
One side is her...
Is this playable on PC?
Yeah, I'm playing it on PC right now.
It's also, you can play it on browser too.
One side is Mei Toki and the other side, the lewd side is
Bunny Toki.
It's so, wait, did I get that right?
I think so.
Or maybe they were both lewd sides.
Akane is best girl of all time.
Akane is side boob city, baby.
Yeah.
So, I checked in both lude sides.
Whoopsie.
But it's really cute, right?
It's like, it's, and if you can find it, it's so soft.
It's so soft.
Yeah.
Oh, Akko!
Sorry, I was thinking of Akko.
You're so right.
I was thinking of Akko.
Naraka name.
Asana got me into the game, but stayed for Hina.
Hina's a good girl.
Oh my gosh, when I was in Japan, they had a Blue Archive
Valentine's event at the Akiba and Atore.
And they had, they had Hina's little floaty.
They had her floaty that she has in her bathing suit.
Not uniform.
Outfit.
And it's like this cute cushion.
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh, it's so, so, it's so cute.
cute um and it's really really soft i like sit on it
sometimes and yeah it's kind of a uniform it's your school
swimsuit yeah that's true and they also had a t-shirt a
t-shirt of her of the of the swimsuit and it's like you
would think that like maybe it's a shirt that's cotton no it
feels like a swimsuit material so i bought it really
oversized so that i can just wear it and like have my little
floaty and pretend that i'm i don't know like this is my
stupid at home cosplay my favorite is the stink ball sorry i
mean ui i forgot i was like playing the other day and i was
like um uh i was like looking up how to i couldn't get
through a battle and um uh i looked it up and it said to it
recommended swimsuit ui and i was like i don't have that but
i did i'm just an idiot anyway majang um i want to go to the
event but we won't because wait how do i oh here we go i
will not go to the event because we have tutorials to do
chapter one majang tiles but guys we're gonna learn majang
today okay we're gonna learn majang today together okay
please help me and then we're gonna roll hello oh here we go
then we're gonna roll we're gonna roll and then play step
one eat the tiles i'm gonna actually also open a note pad so
i can take notes i'm scared baby corner things with the
gifted oh no how do i say your name I'm gonna say Deodato!
Thank you for the five gifted.
How do I say with the squiggly?
Rule on which banner?
Blue Archive, of course!
Okay.
Welcome to Majang Soul...
Welcome to Majang Soul Shrine!
Are you here for fun times playing Majang as well?
No, I'm here for serious times.
Let's learn the basic rules of Majang first.
Majang has 34 different tiles.
They can be sorted into five groups.
Man, Pin, So, Wind, and Dragon.
Man, okay, Man is like the 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Pin is like a pinwheel.
So is so tall bamboo.
Wind is...
east the wind is the directions that it goes in east, south,
northwest dragon is the dragon inside of me inside me there
are two dragons
so tall bamboo
okay there are four of each tile okay Wait, what do you mean
there's four of each tiles?
There's nine.
So in total there are 136 tiles?
Oh, four copies.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I was like, um...
Can you count little cat girl?
Sorry, you can't see her.
She's so cute, though.
She's so cute!
Sequence?
Three consecutive number tiles.
Okay, sequence.
gonna be on the test three consecutive number tiles of the
same group oh i wrote name group of the same group okay so
sequence is like a three three months three pins three so's
triplet is three triplet three identical tiles okay okay and
then pair two identical tiles Okay, we're making notes.
Easy, easy, easy.
Thank God they have the numbers in the corners.
Oh, yeah, if you can't read it, it could be confusing,
right?
Wait.
Okay, I just realized the sequence has to be like 6, 7, 8,
right?
It can't be like 4, 8, 9 or something, right?
Like, it has to be like 3 consecutive consecutive.
Right?
Oh, yeah, yeah, here.
See the sequence.
3, 4, 5, 7, 8, 9, 5, 6, 7.
Can I?
Hold on.
I'm going to put on my glasses.
Putting on my glasses for this so I can really learn.
But...
Okay.
We're good.
I'm learning.
Don't say nerd.
Is she rolling for Hoshino?
I'm rolling for everybody.
Because I like all of them.
All that.
Everybody that's in the collab at least.
I'm so bad.
There's so many girls.
I'm really bad at remembering a bunch of names.
so if you say somebody and i'm like who it's because i'm bad
with the names in blue archive okay four sequences okay wait
okay so four sequences or triplets plus one pair equals
winning winning winning okay so pair is too identical or a
triplet four sequences or triplets plus one pair equals
winning winning winning this game is like poker but tiles
instead of cards you know what I never could understand
poker either so nerd says you with your silly ducky hoodie
would it come on the main objective of majeung is complete a
winning hand it's it means the player has to achieve a hand
consisting of four sequences slash triplets plus one pair to
reach that goal each turn you draw one tile from the tile
wall and if it's not the winning tile you choose one tile to
discard and maintain me main maintain a hand consisting of
13 tiles step by step you will get closer to a winning hand
okay
Who's hand with that?
Oh my god.
Here, let's discard the west tile that's unneeded here.
Yeah, we don't need this one.
That's my hand.
Okay, in addition to the tile group requirement to win, the
winning hand must also contain at least one yak.
What's a yak?
Simple yak.
Wait.
Huh?
Wait, the text is so...
Oh, I have to scroll.
I have to scroll to go through the text.
No, Yaku.
Yaku equals win conditions.
It's a valid hand.
Of course it is.
So, I want to introduce a really popular and easily
achievable Yaku.
All simples.
Also called...
Tanyao, if your hand only has number tiles with numbers from
2 to 8, in other words, does not have honor tiles, wind or
dragon tiles, or terminal tiles, number tiles with one or
nine, then it meets the requirements for all symbols.
So let's try it out.
Okay, so no ones or nines.
Okay, hold on.
Yaku, no one or nine, no wind.
No dragon.
What's this one?
Why is it just blank?
It's like, who?
Who is this?
Who?
Okay.
So just anything else?
Just say 2 through 8.
Yeah, yeah.
2 through 8.
Good.
What's 4 doing all the way over here?
Hmm.
Oh, white dragon.
I don't know.
We already have one triplet.
Yes, right here.
This is our triplet.
The twos.
Sorry, I'm blocking a little bit of it.
Two sequence.
Six, seven, eight.
Here.
And one pair.
wait what's the pair two identical time tiles here here's
our tip here's our pair here's our pair here's our pair so
once we have completed the last sequence we have a winning
hand and it meets the requirement for all symbols get rid of
you when your hand is waiting for the winning tile like this
you are in ten pie if you have yaku and are in ten pie you
just need someone to discard the last needed tile or draw it
yourself to win wait why discard the last needed tile am i
allowed to take their tiles yeah we have double here so we
need us so we have triplet one sequence uh two sequence oh
wait wait wait i have a question if it's so is it four Okay,
if I have two sequences and two triplets, is that okay?
Come on, Zhang is easy.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah.
Yes, that's okay.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Yes, plus the pair.
Ah, so it says four sets in total.
Okay, let me write that.
In, in total.
So four, so, okay.
So we have a one triplet.
One sequence.
One, two sequences.
So we need...
And then a pair.
So we need either a three or we need six.
Okay.
So that'll make three sequences.
And then one triplet, which is four in total.
Oh my gosh, I can do math!
I'm adding addition, subtraction, multiplication.
Give me, okay, that's the title we need.
That one right there, we can win now.
Tap the wrong button.
None.
This is going to take my brain into overdrive.
Holy cow.
Congratulations on the win, yeah!
This is the end of today's practice session.
You can review the tutorial by chapter or just check out the
revision.
Yippee!
Give me the coins.
The copper.
Is that how we do the gotcha?
Hold on, I kind of want to check.
How do we do the gotcha?
Why not take a breather and check out a festival at another
school?
Oh, following the research, recent upheaval at Abido's high
school.
Shiroko and Hoshino followed Sensei's advice and took a bus
to Allied Hyakkiyako Academy for their festival.
Or at least that's what they thought they were doing.
Gacha needs premium currency.
No!
Oh my gosh.
This doesn't look like Allied Hyakkiyako Academy.
Wait, there's a whole story even?
Shiroko stared at the school in front of her with a blank
expression.
Next to her, Hoshino yawned unconcernedly.
Clearly, we're in the wrong place.
Look, the pillar over there says this is Asaha High School.
Is it Allied?
Allied?
And it was shaping up to be such a nice day.
Even you dozed off for a bit, Shiroko.
I thought we were at Allied.
Allied Hyakiyako Academy.
I'm sorry, I should have paid more attention to the name of
the stop.
I'll go see when the next bus arrives.
Give me the gacha.
We went to go to a school festival.
Here is just as good as anywhere.
Why are Abido students at Neo Japan High?
Looks like they're having a festival too.
Why don't we go in and have a little fun?
Look, she must have been late for school.
She's got her toast in her mouth and everything.
If you're sure, then I guess it would be okay.
I'm sure.
Shall we?
What a coincidence.
Oh!
The problem solvers are here.
They're so cute.
Look at them!
Oh, Shiroko is so cute.
There was the blue archive, like, um, what's the word?
The blue archive of, like, anniversary festival thing and
they sold her scarf and her and her ears and her little hair
pin and i bought all of it
just as hoshino and shiroko approached the gates they heard
a voice call out from behind them and turned to see two
familiar figures president niko hachimaru and asagimutsuki
members of infamous problem solver 68 known as the outlaws
of kivotos their four member team is so close-knit that
they've been known to happily split a bowl of ramen between
them they are the inheritors of the masked swimsuit gang's
legacy and build themselves as reliable and trustworthy oh
sorry reliable and trustworthy when it comes to fulfilling
some rather dubious contracts good morning friends of
abido's high school
Who are you also summoned here?
Summoned?
Lord dump.
Yeah, split the ramen bowls for bonding.
No other reason.
No.
No, it's not like...
Oh my gosh, look at the tummy detail on Aru.
Just a rumor I heard.
It's nothing.
Did Asaha High School hire you?
Yeah, we got a last minute call yesterday.
Tough job.
Nothing problem-solver 68 can't handle.
We never leave loose ends.
Kuku.
Hmm, how very professional of you.
I make us look so good.
Aru.
She looks so cute.
Oh my gosh.
They look so good.
Aru prefers big jobs.
But actually, things have been pretty slow.
lately.
We don't have the luxury of being choosy about contracts
right now.
Mutsuki's naughty face, I know.
Ugh.
Are you two just here to hang out?
Yes.
Sensei suggested we should take some time to relax and check
out another school's festival.
Oh, that sounds nice.
Ahem!
It's getting late, Mutsuki, and we shouldn't keep our client
waiting.
It's bad business.
If you'll excuse us.
Aru flashed a perfunctory...
Sm...
Smile.
And set off towards the school.
Muskiy waved goodbye to Hoshino and Shiroko and followed.
Perfunctory.
I don't know much about...
Much of Blue Archive, but I think I've seen that blue cat at
the bank before.
How could you tell from her disguise?
Humph.
Happy Bunchard Day.
Shall we head in too?
Sure.
So the foreclosure task force and problem solver 68 join the
festivities inside Asaha High School.
Oh!
Goshini-sama, Asaha High School is holding a school festival
with lots of fun activities and delicious food, yeah!
Oh my gosh, it's a bomb!
But they are short on men power, so they ask if Master can
help out with approving proposals, Nya!
Ichi and Hime has already said yes and ate the pudding, so
Master can't say no, Nya.
We are number one!
I hear it.
I'm definitely gonna be able to un-hear it.
Nya, Nya!
We already got a proposal here!
Master, let's tap on this proposal and check out the
content, Nya!
I propose we forbid Ichihime from take to take part in the
festival she already has cleared the stock of the snacks
then at the school gate strongly agree master don't take
this prank seriously yeah anyway when you approve a proposal
the three fest stats will change now there's
mashups of the two I can believe it
When the first stats meet the rank-up requirement, the first
rank will go up.
The current rank is E-minus, so we still have a long way to
go.
But I'm sure Master can do it, Nya.
The good news is that Master won't be working alone, Nya.
A few special guests have arrived at the festival, and they
will help you out, Nya.
Let's go meet them now.
Nya,
hold on.
How do I pull them?
How do I get them?
Tutorial.
During the festival, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
Level up, level up.
Confirm.
To the shop?
Where do I pull them at?
Oh, shop.
Wait, they have...
Did they have their own outfits?
Whoa!
She, she, she, she, she, don't go.
Oh my god You haven't gotten this character yet Not yet Oh
my god Oh my god Oh my god so cute Oh it's cute
Wishing star Look how cute The art is all so cute Wow Wait,
whoa, whoa.
Fortune.
Background.
Money for gotchas first, then money for skins.
How do I...
Wait, so the shop is...
Is it summon?
Ah!
Here we are.
Uh-oh.
Let's learn how to...
Wait, what's the difference between Bamboo Club?
The Sakura Club.
Let's learn how to play first.
The more I play, because, you know, I don't want to just
spend money on them and be like, man, I hate Majang.
Let's keep doing the tutorials.
Yeah, let's keep doing the tutorials.
Oh, here's the Yakub.
I hate Majang.
Bamboo has men.
Oh, wait.
Sakura has other female characters.
Bamboo has male.
Oh, no.
Okay, thanks for letting me know.
The red mark on the table has moved.
That means the dealer seated east has changed.
This is an east wind match.
So the match ends when every player has been dealer one
time.
Don't think of running away before the match ends.
When the match ends, the four players will be ranked from
first to fourth.
Do your best to aim for first place.
The east two in the center indicates that the match is the
second game of the East Wind Round.
East Wind is the current prevalent wind.
X69 indicates the number of tiles remaining.
If this number becomes zero, then the game will end even if
no one wins.
What does the prevalent wind mean?
The W in front of you indicates you are seated well.
in this game and West is your seat wind it's
a lot to take in but it does make sense eventually yeah
we're in the W spot a triplet of prevalent wind and a
triplet of seat wind are both very common yakus oh that's
right they said the cut okay so there was the yakus which is
which is what two through eight or so So this is also a yaku
we can have, right?
Yaku high.
So a triplet of a seat wind.
Okay, hold on.
Yaku.
One.
Yaku two.
Um, a triplet of prevalent wind.
So the prevalent wind would then be the, okay, east wind
round.
Oh, so it's because...
Wait, is it east wind round because it's east and I'm
sitting west?
Wait, no.
Oh, never mind.
Sorry.
I was confusing wind and west.
Weast?
I mean, wait.
What?
East?
I thought you meant weast.
Okay.
Now it makes...
I was thinking...
East-West round, but it's East-Wind round.
Okay, that makes so much more sense.
What's the two for, though?
And we are sitting West.
So we can either get the Prevalent Wind or we could get our
Seat Wind.
Prevalent Wind.
Oh, wait.
And a Triplet of Seat Wind.
So you need both.
Okay.
If you get three West Tiles, then you can win with Seat
Wind.
West as Yaku.
Oh, it's either or?
Because it says here and a triplet of prevalent wind and a
triplet of seat wind.
Oh, so, okay, or.
Triplet of prevalent wind or triplet of seat wind.
Both are yakus.
You can get both.
Either, either, either.
Read the whole sentence?
I did!
You can't say that to me when I literally just confused wind
for west, okay?
My brain is small.
My glasses are the wrong prescription.
If any other player discards a tile and you have two tiles
of the same kind in your hand, you can call pawn to form a
triplet.
Upon calling pawn, you shall openly place the triplet formed
in the corner of your table.
Don't miss this tile!
PON!
PONIA!
After you called PON successfully, discard one tile from
your hand.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye tile.
What the hell was this one?
If the player on your left discards a tile that can form a
sequence with two tiles in your hand, you can call CHI on
that tile.
Upon calling CHI, you shall openly place the sequence formed
in the corner of your tib-tib-tib Wait, what did they place?
The six?
Wait.
On my left.
Oh, hold on.
I need to read this again.
Pon and Chi can mess up your hand if you weren't careful.
Go to settings and turn on the tile numbers.
Easier for a while.
Yeah, I will do that.
I didn't know.
I thought it, because it showed it before, I thought it
would stay, but it does not.
Wait, okay.
So the player on my left discards a tile that can form a
sequence with two tiles.
call Chi.
Okay.
Chi only from left hand player.
Pond from any player.
Nyaruhada!
Sometimes you don't want to call Chi, but you don't
understand the bigger hands in it.
Yeah, I don't know anything.
Chi!
Chia!
After you call Chi successfully, discard one tile from your
hand too.
What is this one?
What is that?
Goodbye, too.
Now you've reached Tenpai.
What was Tenpai again?
Oh, wait.
It's when we have a hand, but we're waiting for one thing,
right?
When you draw one pin or four pin,
yourself or someone else discards either tile, you win.
Yeah, one tile from winning.
Ready to win.
kind of remember
confusing kanji at the bottom is man it is this one
okay okay so i need um so they say one pin so we need the
pair right because we have okay sorry i'm gonna be like
explaining everything out so slowly for me to learn this so
we have three wait we have uh okay we have a sequence and we
have our uh our prevalent our prevalent seat wind okay so
now we just need wait and that's it so we need either we
have a we have a sequence here and we have a triplet here
one two three so then if we get this it's a pair or this
it's a pair why couldn't we oh because then it'll break the
sequence okay I get it I get it so this becomes a sequence
and or like this becomes a sequence if we get the four or
this is the sequence this is the sequence and we get the one
okay okay maybe some of us are learning together so this is
kind of good maybe okay so that would make the the yaku 1 2
3 4 okay okay okay well i got it okay okay okay
we got this wait if you four of the same tile you can type
kan these and these tiles will be placed in the right corner
and you get to draw one tile and then discard one tile this
is called a closed kan and the quad formed here is
considered a kind of triplet oh oh oh okay closed kan shame
that we didn't win with the drawn tile let's discard it see
ya Okay, oh, oh, noon!
Come, yam, yam, yam, yam, yam.
Yam, yam, yam.
We won the tutorial.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I'm in Kaiji just a little bit more.
Congratulations on the win.
This is the end of today's practice session.
You can review the tutorial.
Blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
Zawa zawa zawa zawa zawa okay let's get our money copper
okay
oh yeah go to option thank you for reminding me um would it
be under oh uh this one there we go
Perfect, perfect.
Next tutorial.
Oh wait, oops.
You could say nonsense and I believe it was a mahjong term.
The only thing I really knew was don't.
I only really knew about the don't, but I didn't know what
it meant at all.
Now I know what it means.
It means I'm gonna tick your tile.
left corner there are five tiles but only one is revealed
isn't that strange i knew yaku but i didn't know what it
meant nichi is the best because you don't have to do
anything once you're in that state oh yeah no nico's win by
stealing the tile so i have a question can you only don if
you're in the what was that what was that what was that
state called the
Tempai?
Yes, you need to beat Tempai.
I'm going to write that down.
Can only don't tile from another person when in Tempai.
You need one more tile to win.
My notes.
If not, it's just a poem.
Or Chi.
Ah, okay.
If not, it's Pon or Chi.
Wait, okay, so Chi is taking from the left.
From person on left.
What was the Pon again?
I don't remember.
Wait.
The game will let you make wrong calls.
That's okay.
Being in Tempai is like Uno in Uno.
Okay, okay, okay.
PON is for calling triplets.
Ah, okay, PON for calling triplets.
When you have two of a tile and someone discards the third.
Okay, okay.
Okay, thank you.
Taking.
Okay, okay.
And chi is for taking the person, from the person.
The chi is for sequence, but only for the, okay.
taking my person on the left but only for sequence so you
can't do chi for okay so if I take from the person on my
left and it's for a triplet it would just be a poem
chi is for sequence and you can only take from the person
before you pon is for triplets you can take from anyway ah
okay okay
you don't have to worry about the left side thing in this
since it won't let you But it's still good to know in case I
play outside of Majang Sol, right?
So, it's going to be confusing at first.
Yeah, but that's okay.
I think I'm already understanding slowly.
I'm getting, I'm knowing I'm really, I'm really, I'm
understanding better than I did before when I tried.
The best advice I have about mahjong is to avoid calling
tiles until you recognize the yaku that you're building.
Okay, wait, what do you mean by calling titles?
Like by putting them over here on the right side of me over
here?
Good advice.
By calling cheer poem?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Stealing your okay, okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, I'm gonna write that down.
equals taking tiles stealing tiles becoming a criminal of
tiles okay cool so in that regard it feels like poker
because aren't you supposed to hide your hand in poker for
so long crimes crimes I don't know so many vtuber fans knew
how to play mahjong.
I've always been so fascinated when I go to an anime
convention because there's without doubt always a group of
people that are just playing mahjong like somewhere on the
floor.
So I've always been so fascinated to try and learn how to
play because it seems fun.
If it's so fun that there's people that are just like
sitting around playing mahjong.
there are at least four of us i've never seen that that's
crazy really i feel like i've always seen it i have a set i
bring to furry cons no way how do you hold them in your
furry paws this is where mind games come in if you're
calling tiles it also makes it more likely to let the other
players figure out what hand you have yeah that's where like
i said where it feels like poker Hi Emily!
Oh god.
I should watch Saki.
I should finish Saki.
I saw a group of Zombieland Saga cosplayers playing Majang.
Okay.
This is the Dora.
Oh my gosh.
Dora.
Dora, Dora.
She's a gambler.
Dora!
Oh my god, she got into Majang.
Oh my god, boots, she sold boots off to pay for off her
debts.
Dora the majeunger.
The majeunger.
Dora the gambler.
They will indicate the shining Dora tiles.
The tiles, wait, the tile next in order after the revealed
indicator tile is Dora.
If the one man is revealed.
Ah!
Oh, oh, that scared me.
Then the two man in your hand is Dora.
Huh?
Swiper, no swiping credit cards.
Wait, what?
Soy gambler!
Hola!
Okay, this confused me the most.
Shiny tiles equals more points, basically.
Okay.
Dora is the next tile from the revealed tile.
Shiny tiles equals bonus points.
So if I have
but this one's shiny.
The two.
The tile necks in order after the revealed and then...
Oh, so because this is revealed, then this would be the
shiny, the Dora.
It's sorry, not the... Wait.
It's Dora.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Is it just in my hand or...
So if you're like trying to really big brain it, you would
want to get like a sequence with the Dora.
With Dora or like a triplet Dora or something like that.
Dora's are for everyone.
Okay.
So if one is revealed, then two is Dora.
Okay, okay, okay.
More Dora, the better.
Yummy point.
Okay, okay, okay.
You guys are so helpful today.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys.
When you win, the more Dora tiles you have in your hand, the
more points you win.
Oh, I didn't even...
It's not even letting me put anything down.
It's like you're still too stupid, okay?
Oh, another Yaku.
Another Yaku is...
Richi.
Okay.
When Richi is possible, the following button will appear.
You need to pay 1,000 points as Richi bet.
Richi is best yaku.
Okay, when you have neither all simples nor triplet of
prevalent seat wind, what can you do?
Since we haven't called chi or pon yet, we can call Richi.
It's also a very common yaku.
Okay, so I don't have...
All Simples.
Nor a triplet of...
Okay.
It's the lock-in button.
When need to use possible, the following button will appear.
Wait, call is not allowed.
Because this is the triplet of the prevalent or seat wind.
Because it's east wind.
Or I'm sitting west.
right so that's why i can't call the dc because i have to
have neither all symbols
the dc button is so satisfying to press once you're dc you
can't see your point or or what Bajai, was you right?
Hello, Mind.
My favorite vegetable introduced me to your lives, and I'm
enjoying it.
Can you send a hug to Lucas for me, please?
Hugs from Brazil.
Thanks, Roy.
Hi, Lucas.
If you feel a chill, it's me.
Thank you.
Game will play itself once you go into DG.
Oh, really?
Okay.
Well, I'm just going to keep going.
Tap the Ritchie button, pay 1000 points as Ritchie bet and
discard a tile to make your hand tempai Okay, so hold on.
Let's see why this makes it tempai.
So we have a sequence one sequence two sequence a triplet
So that's three Thanks takizou you can meet you as long as
you haven't stolen any tiles that round doesn't have to be
all simple Oh, okay, okay, okay.
And then we have four pair.
So all we would need is another sequel.
We didn't need a five or an eight, right?
Mm.
So that's why we get rid of this.
Okay.
Nietzsche.
While paying a thousand points is a pain, and you can't
change your hand after calling Nietzsche, you will have
Nietzsche as Yaku, and you only need to draw a tile, discard
it until you win.
But I can't steal, so I have to be lucky.
I win!
Ipatzuma!
Okay.
Ipatz is a yaku that comes into effect if the player wins
within the next turn after declaring Richi, i.e.
before their next discard, without interruptions from other
players' calls.
Oh my gosh.
Friendinator, think you're the Akasuba!
It's dangerous to gotcha without money.
Here, take this.
No!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
As a reward for winning with Niti, you also get the chance
to have another Dora coming into effect.
Let's check out what the Ura Dora tile is.
Tzumo.
Oh!
Hidden Dora.
We had no...
We had no hidden Dora though.
No, no Uradora.
Zanen.
Yippee!
It's a pity we didn't have any Uradora tiles in our hand.
But even like this, we win with bigger winning points since
we have both Bichi and Ipatz.
Okay.
Congratulations on the win!
This is the end of today's bl-l-l-l-l-l-l-l.
Okay.
Okay, so Ipatz.
I didn't write anything.
for Dichi wait I wrote no notes for Dichi okay can call when
you when you haven't called chi or poem like
Nietzsche is just click it if you see it but like and then
nipatz is when after Dichi thank you nipatz when after win
right after calling Li-Ti.
and all, and all, know all symbols or wins.
And know all symbols or wins.
So, I'm kind of confused.
What's like the, what's like the benefit of calling Li-Ti?
Oh, it's just a Yaquan.
Li-Ti is riskier, but worth more points.
Okay, okay, okay.
You don't need any other yaku.
Ah, ah, ah,
ah.
More yaku is more points so it can stack.
Richie is a yaku easy to get because game is called Richie
Majongajong.
I don't know.
If you win with a Richie, you'll be rich.
My friend asked me how much I had to super to get you to
play Majang.
I'm so glad my Kamiyoshi is finally playing one of my
favorite games.
Thanks, Nicholas!
Help me out then.
Thank you.
You can only get Uradora.
Oh, okay.
Only...
You can only get Uradora if you win...
Let me write Dora, Dora equals bonus point shiny special
tile.
You can ignore all other Yaku, so very beginner friendly.
You're a certified grandma now after this?
have one more chapter and then I gotta do the test which I'm
really scared for.
Okay.
Oh, you're awake!
Did I die?
I have played the game halfway for you, yeah.
Check out your hand.
We have so many mandiles, yeah!
Sorry, this hand looks a bit weird.
Okay.
Simply, Yaku, half,
Is this the...
Wait, what was it called?
Like a...
She's sabotaging you.
I'm afraid it's been nine years.
Look at your arm.
No!
Bro, if these are simple, what's a complex, Yaku?
For real?
all right okay
may only contain number tiles of one suit and triplet or
pair of honor tiles okay can only contain number tiles of
one suit and triplet or pair of honor tiles so the honor
tiles are the the um the dragon one right
uh dragons wind wind and dragons okay
okay okay while it is worth three han after you make a call
the worth will be one hand less i.e.
become two hand okay this hand is aiming for a yaku called
half flesh where aside from honor tiles all the number tiles
belong to one suit currently we're waiting for one four
seven month oh my gosh one one one two three four five six
seven making this a very advantageous hand
but why are we waiting for the one or the four or the seven
wait
13 orphans Sounds scary
Oh I can't Oh I'm looking at this like it's my hand I'm a
dummy Sorry it's alright Yeah you're right you're right We
can't see our Okay okay Yes down here Down here is our hand
Okay It's a meme hand 13 orphans But as we discarded the one
man before That means we are in Tempai Waiting for tiles,
including the one that was discarded before by ourselves.
This status is called discard Furi-ten.
Oh, okay.
So, yeah, we're waiting for one.
Five, six, seven.
Oh.
When one is in Furi-ten, they can only win by Tzumo.
Okay, hold on.
When in Furi-ten, you can only win by Tzumo.
And not run.
Oh.
Calling on another player's discard.
I'm just... I feel like, you know when you like take notes
from a class and you just type exactly what was written on
the PowerPoint that the teacher had on the board, that's how
I feel right now.
Furi-ten is bad, basically.
Okay.
Aside from discard Furi-ten, are also two other types of
Furi-ten called temporary Furi-ten and Dichi Furi-ten.
But I won't go deep into these here, Nya.
Thank you.
Oh, goodbye.
Girl, we can't wait for the other three players to discard
any of the winning tiles on this situation.
Try to draw the winning tile on your own.
Believe in yourself.
That's a win by Tumo for you!
Good job!
Summonia!
Chang!
Mm-hmm.
Yippee!
It's not like it was a tutorial or anything.
So, so if I, if I were to have, uh, won by DT, wait, no, if
I were to have gotten, use these, the, the soul, the soul
tiles, the thing.
three soul tile would have been the dora right raiders hi
raiders hello my name is mint phantom and right now my my
brain is leaking out my ears thank you thanks for the raid
ray mac thanks for the five gifted if you won by dita you
would have gotten 1 000 more points minimum and then we
could have also maybe gotten the hidden dora oh my brain i'm
only playing this game because I like Blue Archive, you
guys.
Taki, thanks for the gifting.
Thank you.
Three soul would be the Dora, but not usable in your head.
No, no, no.
Not usable in my head.
Okay.
That's why I was saying if I had Richid, then that would
have been...
I'm just applying what I learned in the last episode.
Okay.
Murphy, thanks for the five gifting theme.
money okay let's go over what we learned oh hi there new
player my name is Ichihime never played mahjong before oh
well let me teach you that okay 34 different tiles so we
have the man we have the pin we have so let's see remember
man um one man two men three men four men okay we have pin
which pin will miss melchan thank you for the vibe you Thank
you.
If you don't memorize the number slash wins, everyone will
think you're a scrub.
I am a scrub.
I don't know what I'm doing.
So one man, two man, three man.
Then you have the pin whales.
Then you have the so tall bamboo.
Then you have the wins.
Because wind goes in east direction.
Wind goes in south direction.
Wind goes in west direction.
Wind goes in north direction.
Then you have the dragons.
The dragon, there are two dragons inside of me.
understand?
The objective of Majong is to win, of course.
So how do you win a game?
In a game, each player usually has 13 tiles in hand.
No.
But there are three dragons.
There are three dragons inside of me.
There's no, okay, this is what, see, this is the kind, this
is Naka, so inside.
So then you have the dragon, and then Then you have the who?
Dragon.
Is it weird that I'm kind of super invested in you learning
mahjong now?
You have gah.
Then you have who?
Who?
Who is that I mean?
Nice memorization.
Thank you!
Discard the dragon you don't want.
Oh, sorry, not the dragon.
Discard the card you don't want.
And we have to get...
Certain conditions and every turn you will draw a tile so
the number of tiles becomes 14 and you shall discard What
from your head?
Why am I yawning?
I had coffee We have to okay before explaining how to win
first understand three terms sequences Triplets and pairs
first we have pairs two identical Then we have triplets
three identical and then we have a sequence three
consecutive tiles of the same group easy peasy this one this
part's easy this part's easy Yeah, 5, 6, 7, so tall bamboos.
7, 8, 9 people.
Oh, 7, 8, 9 people.
That's a lot of people to eat.
And then 4, 5, 6 pinwheels.
Pin.
Usually when your hand consists of four sequences or
triplets, plus one pair, you are ready to win, master.
Of course, in me, Tsumajong, you must satisfy other
conditions to declare a win.
We will cover them later.
So, we have to get...
Um, four sequences or triplets, so we can have one sequence,
three triplets, two triplets, two sequences, but we also
need a pair.
And other conditions.
This is the most important sign.
Yeah.
Mm.
You can also do four sequences or four triplets.
Yes, you could do four sequences or four triplets.
Yes.
Thank you.
Yeah, the other conditions are the yaku.
So there's, so far I know four different yaku.
Yeah.
Of course, your hand also often consists of 13 tiles only.
So you need one more to win.
When you just need one more tile to win, this hand is called
tempai.
step necessary step before winning so make sure you pay
attention to it so the
so if we have four five if we have a if we get six then we
would win because we would have this three sequences
triplets and what this would make another or we could get a
three we get a three or a six and then that would be the
pair my are all pairs easy to remember that does sound easy
okay that's correct seven pairs is a yakutu yes wait seven
pairs really did I learn that one it's
also a meme hat you can make seven pairs seven pairs is bad
which tile does the hand need for winning oh let's see we
got we have a pair here of twos four five six we have a
sequence three four oh probably this two right well one
sequence two sequence three sequence two
Statistically speaking, you're close to seven pairs once you
have five in your hand.
Which tile does the hand need for winning?
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
This would be our pair.
Right?
Yeah.
We need the three because we need the pair.
Right?
Yippee!
Yeah!
Okay.
Wait.
Am I dumb?
We don't have...
Actually, I don't understand.
No, you're smart.
Oh, it turns this one into a pair and then one two...
This is the pair.
I was like,
I knew that the whole time.
I knew that the whole time she failed successfully.
Yep.
Yup.
A winning hand must contain a yaku.
If you achieve 10-5, I have no yaku.
A no yaku notice will be shown.
That's so scary.
That sounds so scary.
Simple yaku.
Yakuhai.
You know, I don't think I wrote these.
Which yaku I'm doing.
So this is the one where you refer to the...
Oh wait, no.
Yeah, this is the one with...
The triplets of the prevalent wind or the seat wind?
Or the dragon?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Three dragon tiles or...
Yeah, or the dragon tiles.
Yakuhai equals three dragons or seat wind, east wind.
Okay.
All symbols.
Oops, all simples.
Okay, yes, this is all, okay, all simples.
No yaku.
There are some yaku cheat sheets you can look up for quick
reference sheet.
I might need it because I'm writing all this down, but I'm
more of a visual person than anything else.
So, hmm.
Writing it down might be completely pointless for me.
You must not have any of the tiles below, which is 1 and 9,
or any of the wins, or any of the dragons.
Okay, Niti.
When Niti is possible, the following button will appear.
And then I have to pay a thousand points.
When you achieve Tempai without calling Ti, Pon, or Kan.
Yes.
Kan.
Kamen child.
Called Ti or Pon or Kan.
And no simple...
Wait.
Wait, is it no...
No all symbols or wins?
Oh wait, so it's gotta be...
No all symbols and no all wins, right?
Closed Kan from your own hand is allowed.
Oh, let me write that down too.
Closed Kan.
You can have all symbols or wins.
wins you can okay i wrote that down maybe i misunderstood um
okay it doesn't matter what you have in your hand okay okay
okay all wins is a billion points since it's giga rare are
you winning minto i don't
know dichi lets you win even if you don't have anything else
okay going on a trip so i can't watch the stream we'll watch
the vibe later have fun wrecking your brain and Majong, it
ate all my brain cells when I played it.
Thanks, Mason!
Thank you!
Which of the following sequence is a Yaku?
Yaku...
East?
It's an East game, and we're East Seat.
So East.
Seekai, niya!
Nice.
Which tile should you discard if you want achieve tanyao for
all wait for all symbols you must not have any oh wait we
can't have the one
i wish they wouldn't switch between the terminology either
call it all symbols forever or call it tanyao forever you
know what i mean or at least always put like like tanyao
Parentheses, simple's.
Mm-mm.
Now that we have learned the tiles and some yaku, let's
check out the game interface.
Master, please look at the screen above.
I shall explain to you one by one, yeah.
East one.
Means that you are the first game of the East Wind Round.
East is your current round wind.
67 means the tiles remaining.
Uh...
My points.
Discard tiles.
Discard tiles you don't want.
Or tiles you don't want.
You can call the discard tiles for ti pong kan.
Chi is the call to complete a sequence.
Chi is...
Chi is when...
Hold on.
Chi is...
When I...
call from the person on my left for the sequence.
She is a yoink for sequence, correct?
YIVY!
Okay.
Um...
So yeah, okay.
Last player, left side, discarded tile form a sequence with
two tiles, so...
Six...
8, and they drop the 7.
Here the 7-pin discarded by the last player could be used to
form a sequence of 6-7-8-pin.
PON is when anybody...
PON is when somebody, anybody...
Places a tile, discards a tile that I want to steal.
And I go steal!
And then I take it for...
Okay, for...
For...
Triplet.
Steel!
Yoink!
Hey guys, I'm here in the Florida Everglades.
Oh look, a shiny spider.
Yoink.
A shiny tile.
Full on Konosuba Steel.
Yeah.
The steel, just like the fear.
Hi.
Hi this.
Minto.
Are you guys watching Konosuba?
the season two?
Yes.
So let's make the triplet home.
This is the call to complete a quad.
Khan can be called on discarded tiles from any player.
You can also make a Khan call when you have four identical
tiles in your hand or has a previously melded triplet.
That's why I confused.
Season three.
Wait, what did I say?
Wait, what did I, did I say?
say like people were oh did i say season two oh my bad yeah
i meant season three my bad my bad so people were saying
that con is not so great people is this one kind of only
used if i am desperate oh
yes I meant this see yes see I was like I don't think I said
which sees which season number it was so yes I was meaning I
was saying like are you watching it this season to as in are
you watching it this season as well Khan reveals more Dora
oh does it this calls to complete a quad okay Let me write
Khan.
I don't think I wrote Khan down.
Khan equals calling to complete a quad.
It can be called on discarded tiles from any player.
You can also make a Khan call when you have four identical
tiles.
That's the closed Khan, right?
If I call it on the ones that are in my hand?
It's bad at higher expert play.
It's fine at lower mid-level play.
Oh, okay, okay.
Khan will reveal more Dora, which might give your opponent
an advantage too.
Oh, okay, okay.
Close Khan is best for you.
Mm-mm-mm-mm.
When identical tiles in your hand or have a previously
melded triplet the fourth tile.
Oh, interesting.
Okay.
Learning the basic hand composition and the yaku is a lot
more simple than it seems at first.
The real challenge is figuring out the scoring.
It might help to watch Saki just so you can see all the yaku
man hands that you'll only get with MC luck.
True, true, true.
Kan is the Saki finisher.
This is making me want to watch Saki though.
Which of the following hands can tea the sixth from the last
player?
Tea is the, oh my gosh, the sequence.
So it would be this one.
Which snack do you want to have first?
I'm not a snack, yeah?
What are you talking about?
Which of the following hands can pawn from another player?
Pon is a triplet, so this one.
YIVY!
Okay, Chi sequence.
Pon triplet.
Chi sequence.
Si, chi sequence.
Pon triplet.
That's enough the basic rules master.
Remember we have learned the tile groups.
Mind soul, ping, wind and dragon.
Three simple yaku, yaku, Go high, all simple is in DT, the
equation of winning.
Four sequences or triplets plus one pair.
You can practice your skills with AI by creating a private
game room, or if you are interested in more advanced rules,
you can find them by tapping the question mark icon on the
top right corner.
I'm going to sleep, yeah.
We did it!
Tutorial, oh my gosh, I graduated.
Look at my little hat.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, what does this do?
How cute!
That's so fun.
Okay.
Send help, I'm stuck in Majong Limbo, I can't get out of
bronze.
One of my most recent matches I lost in the first draw?
Am I gonna be okay?
Okay, I think what I'm gonna do...
I think I should do gotcha.
And then I will play a game against the AI.
I think I will do the gotcha.
And then I will play the game against the AI.
How much is it to summon 10 times?
Purchase.
Wait, I'm scared.
Is it going to show something?
Hold on.
I'm getting rid of the window real quick.
Oh, okay.
Do you know that in the manga Akagi, there was a single
maijan game that took 20 real life years to finish?
a single night in the mongo 20 years real life it's like 40
dollar wait what okay hold on how much is it you need 1800.
that's really expensive check your mail for free stuff oh oh
where's my mail where's my mail do i have mail I don't think
I have met...
Oh, items, maybe?
Illustration?
I got this one, at least.
Yippee!
I don't think I have anything.
Oh, under the event.
Mutsuki.
Not this event.
The button that says event.
Oh, this one.
500 fest budget I
have nothing I have nothing no freebies they don't even let
you do a free temple they don't even let you do a free
temple that's so sad oh my gosh though this is expensive
And what does it mean first purchase?
Oh, like the first purchase, I'll get the bonus, but usually
I won't get the bonus.
That's so messed up.
Okay.
We'll do two tent pulls and see what happens.
Is the gotcha on this really stingy?
Wait, oh, I don't think I have my wallet with me.
I think I have to go get my purse.
I have to go get my purse, you guys.
Give me one second.
go get it check the rates where does it say it
oh my gosh good luck man gotcha my young soul is kind of
brutal thanks oh my gosh thank you for the hackathon gotcha
fun enjoyment thank you so much wait um this artist uh um i
recognize i recognize this artist
Isn't this Lise's Mama from...
Isn't this Lise Sama's Mama?
Fuji Choco!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I knew it, I knew it.
Poti Mama is a character as well?
Wait, can I identify it?
Can I identify Poti Mama's art?
It's not this one, is it?
Close but no
cigar.
It's not this one, is it?
Second last row.
Oh, oops.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
I don't even see this one!
Ah!
That voice by Ho-chan!
Wait.
This one.
I'm so confused.
Ah!
I was like, I don't know.
I was like, this doesn't look like, this doesn't look like.
But it's Ho-chan so it's okay.
I'm so confused.
Wait.
Ah!
I see it now.
I see it now I see I was immediately when I saw her I was
like I see it I saw it immediately This artist also looks
familiar Tange Sakura
There's so many cute characters girl i'm on no for gotcha
you might want to hide your screen when clicking the jade to
be safe i will i will for sure thank you though for the
reminder
looks like sennan kagura this one no i don't know where it
looks familiar to me though
pochi sensei always has like those very like very
distinctive eyes which is why i was like looking at these
two because Pochi Sensei's eyes are always so sharp you know
what I mean
okay let me go get my wallet I'll be right back I know where
my purse is I'll be right back
okay I'm back
I'm glad I have savings because um PayPal is put hold on all
the money so i actually haven't had any i haven't been able
to get any of the money so far that you guys have donated i
won't be able to get it for three months so so uh um credit
card okay i'm gonna hide my um okay purchase um i'm gonna
get the 1800.
uh it's not gonna like show my okay i'm scared
okay put in my credit card i'm definitely i'm like triple
checking that i'm in my screen okay
warning do not open for three months okay I'm so scared I
don't think you guys can see but I'm still scared I'll only
unhide once we're back on the normal the screen
I'm scared
okay pay close your eyes yeah close your eyes Successfully
purchased 1,800 Jade.
Yippee!
Okay, close.
And...
Da-da-da!
Okay.
Summon.
I would really be happy with anybody.
Truly.
But if I were to rank them, I would want Shiroko Aru Hoshino
Mutsuki.
I shouldn't have said that.
I just jinxed myself, didn't I?
My offering to your gacha gods.
Oh my god, Tangisao!
No!
Don't!
Don't Saka's don't know, please!
Shiroko is so cute.
She is.
Clearly the solution is to overload PayPal with money, so it
explodes its hours here with our donuts.
No, no, no.
Musuki at the bottom, Saj.
It's because...
Shiroko has to be at the top for me because she's my Seiyu
Oshi.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for the Supas.
I'm just taunting with this money at this point.
Going for PayPal high score
I'm requesting your professional opinion on Ichinose Asuna.
Asuna.
Like Asuna smile.
I love Asuna.
My offering for the three month long Broko's face.
No.
Gotcha tax get that out.
Yeah, the desire sensor has been activated.
So okay, I'm gonna I'm not gonna look I'm not gonna look
Wait, actually, how do I know if I got something good right?
Top whoa Whoa, I got a teddy bear.
That's not a girl.
Uh-oh Purple streaks Uh-oh So this is not good.
I got green streaks delicious cookie what the hell is all
this stuff where's the girls oh a lavender tablecloth though
winning hard-boiled shot squeeze it's wine glass oh my god
god we're gonna stop for gotcha hopefully you can get this
sooner thank you please guys don't feel like you have to
please don't feel like you have to donate please please
please serious I'm dead I'm dead serious please Especially
if it's on gotcha.
Please, this is dumb purchases.
Don't.
Do not.
Do not encourage this.
But I'll cap at like maybe $100.
Or two.
Purple.
Pyrobug, thank you.
If you can read this, please give mint money.
Thank you.
This is fine.
this is fine normal dress what are all the items for classic
painting my gosh keyboard thank you not encouragement but
yes oh oh oh my god we got the shittim we got something blue
archive the blue sky of shittim that's okay I Actually, I'm
quite happy about that.
She's undead, serious.
She's undead, unsurious.
That's quite the name.
That is actually what it's called in Blue Archive, the
Shittim chest.
Exquisite.
Oh, sorry.
What is this?
Rainbow Trail.
Decoration to equip.
And this one.
Um.
Be now the great snake.
Oh, and this one's also limited.
Oh, and this one too!
So we did get a few...
We got three of the limited things at least.
Star of Peroro.
Wait, how do I...
How do I equip...
The thingy.
The Ritchie effects and music are far more fun thing to get
in game.
Dorm?
Decoration.
Uh...
Don...
Reichi.
Oh yeah, we have no music, you're right.
Tableclot.
Oh, it's so pretty!
We didn't get anything else, yeah.
Okay, save.
Um...
Items can be gifted to characters to bond them.
Oh, you need to get five bond hearts to unlock the
characters' voice lines for Yaku.
Ah!
Got it, got it.
I wish, I wish, I wish.
Okay, hide screen.
Um...
Maybe it's worth getting the 2400 since you get the bonus
2400.
Wait, what?
There's a 4900 one?
Wait, go away, go away.
Oh, wow!
There's an eight!
What?
There's an $80 one?
I didn't even see that!
Oh!
What?
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Defended my PhD dissertation yesterday.
I wanted to say thanks for so many fun streams I watched
while prepping.
Good luck with the gacha.
Oh my gosh.
Congrats!
How do I say your name?
Zesby?
Congratulations!
Oh my gosh, doctor.
So smart.
sharing some ajang sands after luck maxing aru first poll
make sure you check your junk for blue items for a free poll
i already did check but thank you okay um i'm not gonna i'm
not i'm not so invested to go in all so quickly yet what
what card did i use thank you okay this one Credit card.
Do I have to put it in again?
I do.
La la la la la la la.
I'm actually...
You know, I could use this on actual Blue Archive.
Am I stupid?
I've...
To be honest, I'm spending more on this than I've spent in
actual Blue Archive.
Is that kind of crazy?
Okay.
Whatever.
Kind of crazy.
Summon.
So this gives me how many how many summons.
Someone help, please.
Fake me!
Totally not for gotcha.
Thank you for the akatsupa.
Thank you.
Two?
With some left over.
Purple.
I got a bone?
I got a bone to pick with you.
Railgun event is soon too.
It's okay, I have some jemmies saved up.
Laser blast.
We
got the pet out all.
At least we got that, I guess.
Oh, you're right.
I don't...
It's like almost enough to do a second one.
Or a third one, I mean.
Whooshah!
Are there...
Um...
Can the...
Can the game...
Like, uh...
Wow, gorgeous dress.
You have terrible luck.
Um...
Yeah, actually, I do.
This is like, it's part of my, um, it's part of my charm.
It's just, it's one of my, it's one of my charm points.
How, how bad my luck is.
This is some of the worst I've seen.
Sorry, man.
That's okay.
It's part of my charm point that I have such bad luck.
Going to my first Hollow Life concert tomorrow, I'm super
excited.
I'm going to be a billion times more excited if such when
you decide to do a concert and I can go to that too.
Oh my gosh, how fun though, Pat!
Wait, what's the concert?
Okay.
How much do I need to to get, what is it, 800?
Oh, Dreamhack in Melbourne!
Melbourne.
The $5 one.
Six.
Okay, you're right.
Okay.
Goodbye.
$5.
To you, my young soul.
Melbourne.
Are you going to Melbourne, mate?
I have like this, um...
What's the word?
What?
No!
Wrong for Robin, no!
Imagine spending money on Gacha.
Who would do such a thing?
Also, what have you done while you were still alive to get
cursed with such luck?
Well, actually, I'm kind of cursed.
My ghost family were all kind of cursed, you know?
Wait, making sure you can't see it all of a sudden.
Basically, I have a curse upon my family.
Not the sand.
How did you know?
How did you know it was a sand curse?
How did you know that?
How did you know?
We're psychic?
Sand curses are so common.
Ah, I see, I see, I see, I see.
I see.
Classic curse trope.
Ah!
I see, I see.
Yeah.
I took a family vacation once.
on that family vacation, my mom, she was told not to touch
the sand.
And you know what she did?
She brought it home.
And ever since then, my family has been cursed.
My, my ectoplasm line.
I wonder if it counts as bloodline.
I mean, I
don't know.
Oh my gosh, Link, thank you for the hacka stuff.
Apologies for being an enabler.
Oh my gosh.
You guys.
Gacha's too scary on stream.
This is why I never do gacha on stream.
But I was like, it's Blue Archive.
Okay.
Also, what does this mean?
Is there a pity?
Oh, wow.
That's a really high pity.
Holy cow.
Return the sound, or suffer my curse.
Oh, stop!
Chironcha, please.
A wild Chiro appears.
Chiroko, come home.
I'm not gonna look.
Did I get it?
I got it!
Okay.
Oh!
Ah!
You know what?
I'll take it!
Oh, we got more music!
Path to V- or not, we got any music.
Normal dress.
A delicate fanzine.
Diamonds.
Yippee!
Me.
The desire sensor.
The Desire Sensor called it, you know?
I'm glad you got someone.
I know.
When Desire Sensor was just like, Um, Mutsuki last.
We'll have you change that.
That, um, that perception.
You can always keep pulling.
I do kind of wanna.
I wanna get at least Shiroko.
Hold on, though.
Why do I go to my dorm?
Ooh!
That my body's going to be in that bag.
Let's see.
Did I get anything here?
I got the music, though, right?
We'll try that one.
In the back, we got the Perro Rosa, mom.
Double click to use her?
Wait, didn't I...
Did I not...
Oh, thank you.
Um, I don't think we had anything else.
Wee!
I want to get different hands, too.
You can listen to the music here.
You can.
Oh, there it is.
I do, um...
Maybe play around to reset your luck.
Good, good plan.
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
Look at that violin.
I can never tell the difference between a viola and a
violin.
Oh wait, save?
Why is it so quiet?
Viola is just deeper sounding?
It's so quiet.
Um...
Uh...
You know what, okay, let's do, would a friendly match be the
one with the AI or...
Wait, how do I play with the computers?
Ah, show.
Create room?
Limited.
Thinking time.
I need a lot of thinking time.
Friendly create AI.
Oh, versus AI.
There we go.
Thank you guys.
It's so quiet.
Okay, so this is my first game.
We're gonna play with the AI.
What?
Where's the music?
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, oh, um, okay.
Let's see.
We could get four, five, six.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, hold on.
We have five, six, seven.
Yeah.
Three, four.
We have a pair.
Okay, I'm tossing this.
Oh, this is so stressful now.
Um, we don't want these two those and it seems like we're
going for the for the Simples one, right?
Maybe maybe Simples would be easiest.
So get rid of you Dang They're just getting rid of those.
Ah
Maybe this one
Okay.
Now we have...
Maybe I get rid of one of the five...
Wait.
We have a pair of fours.
I get rid of the five.
So we have five, six, seven.
Maybe.
Four?
Get rid of the four?
Get rid of four mon.
Oh, four mon.
Wait, why?
Hold the pins.
Okay, I'll hold the pins.
Four mon.
Okay.
I have to pay attention to what they're... Oh, we have a
triple!
a triplet um maybe i get rid of the three then because i
have the triplet we're not going for the the sequence
anymore three bamboo okay we're on the same we're on the
same page everybody good good good uh oh goodbye goodbye
east maybe ah oh I don't think we need this one either too
though right the five yeah
sayonara dragon inside of me nope nope toss it okay sayonara
dragon inside of me okay oh Chi?
Oh!
Wait, should I call it?
Should I do the Chi or should I...
Because it's the five man.
No?
Skip?
Okay.
You shouldn't yet.
Don't open your hand.
Thanks, guys.
I have a pair, I have a pair, pair, pair, so go buy six.
Oh,
wait.
Oh.
The door, yeah, rip door.
It's okay, though.
Did you do it?
I'm scared.
What do I do?
Wait, what do I do?
Wait.
What do I do here?
Oh, I have 10 seconds!
Wait, what do I do?
what's going on wait now i'm actually so confused oh wait
the game is playing for me wait can i sumo wait sumo is
which one again that's the one where you um sumo
yippee yippee yippee tumo is your jewelry winning tie oh
that's right right that's right okay when it gets a little
fast my brain is like can't keep up oh okay my brain my
brain is can't keep up okay hold on let's see I have I have
a pair here to pair here I'm gonna get I need all my notes
in in in format of pictures.
Oh my gosh.
Tough hand, not gonna lie.
If you hit the R on the side, it will auto-call your win.
No, I want to learn, though.
Six bamboo?
Get rid of the...
Either toss the 8P or the 6S.
Drop the soul.
Okay.
no skip skip skip for now six bamboo people are crazy hey
everyone's gonna have their own oh um okay four six eight
nine um maybe wait um
The tool?
I'm looking, wait, it's half flush again.
Oh my gosh.
I need more time to think.
Can I only contain one suit, triplet?
Honor tiles.
Oh, oh.
Wait.
No.
I don't know what to throw out.
Goodbye.
Shoot.
That was bad.
I should have.
I should have just picked something.
Oh, we got the six though.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I'm sure, I'm like half reading my notes.
Dragon tiles.
Or prevalent wind.
I'm south.
So, and we're on, well, I could get the east wind maybe if I
get any more.
Yeah.
Nine mine are east.
Really?
the nine man nine man okay oh
I don't need the two
oh wait we're keeping the west be any good what would it hmm
hmm hmm drop the west oh yeah cuz I'm yeah I'm South Sea
goodbye oh oh to okay this is hard oh maybe East is dead oh
because it's oh oh because they're here okay Goodbye, East.
No!
Drop you.
Wait, Poon for what?
The two?
I could get the triplet.
But I can still also get triplet of four.
I'm gonna skip.
Oh, oh, I got a seven.
Oh, I got a seven!
Wait, so I can get rid of this four, right?
Four man out.
Toss the white.
Oh, we got eight.
Okay.
I guess we'll get rid of the white.
Sayonara.
Bye-bye.
Ah, goodbye.
Skip.
Never be pun.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh, ah!
Mmm...
Skip.
Never cheat.
Oh, wait.
We ended up getting the nine anyway.
That's so funny.
But...
Can you move over to the... Oh, yeah, yeah.
Give me a second.
Can I pause?
Yeah, I'll move over a little bit so you can't use conceal.
There you go.
Oh, not that.
It's not paused?
Oh, oh, oh, ah!
Um, oh, oh, oh, oh, you can't pause?
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
8p.
Thank you, guys.
I don't know what I would do without you.
I am trying to think for myself.
Goodbye.
I'm not trying to rely on you guys too much, but also
goodbye.
Dang, that would have maybe been kind of good though.
Wait, why is it red?
Why is it different?
You got this.
T-A!
T-A, I'm scared.
Dora?
Wait, what's the Dora?
Hold on, I need my notes.
Oh, it is shining.
It is shining.
So keep.
Maybe get rid of the six?
Or...
Nine months?
Six or nine months?
We'll get rid of the nine months.
Why did I get six?
I said six earlier.
I'm going to commit.
I'm going to commit to the bit.
Oh, we don't need goodbye.
What am I pawning for?
Uh...
Oh!
Wait.
Wait, should I for the 8?
So we can get the triple?
Wait.
Skip, really?
Eh?
Never be pawned.
Seven pairs.
Wait, I...
Skip?
Okay, I'll skip.
I trust you guys.
We're going for seven pairs.
I trust you, Chie.
I skip, I trust you.
Anything Chie says, Chie is God.
GG.
General rule of thumb for your first discards is
non-Yaku-Hai wins first, then isolated ones, and nines, then
Yaku-Hai.
If you have a pair of any of the above, you should usually
keep it.
Whoa!
We have two Easts!
go we have two eights um let's see um now you pon east okay
pon time what should i toss though um i can toss the west
though can i toss the west
drop a w okay
I don't really need this either I will drop three so the
nine pin six or nine pin I could drop either of them yeah
we'll drop the nine pin
we'll keep a five pin right we have pair here
this sick is good for sequence maybe okay let's get one of
the rid of the one it's your mom no skip um
you could have tea if you kept one yeah but me get rid of
the ap really okay well I could get six seven eight I have
no idea what I'm forming I'm just playing drop it it doesn't
help okay
skip four oh we have a sequence of four five six okay okay a
seven would make five six we have four five six though so i
can draw the or i can wait we have one two uh we can drop
either one of these then right so let's drop the let's drop
the the one because we could do two three four
oh me thank you for the 20 gift Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you!
Wait, drop the 8?
I guess because we already have other pairs.
And this will make a triple?
Okay.
Or a sequence, I mean.
North.
Go away.
Uh, we don't need it.
Let's get rid of the 7s.
Yeah.
Toss.
Come on!
Oh what?
Keep it?
My bad.
Why would I, why should I, um, why should I have kept it?
Just so I know.
Makes one three five.
you can finish.
Wait, one three five is a thing?
One three five shape is good.
Ah, the two does nothing.
Because two is more useless right now.
Oh, one three five can be good.
Ah, I see, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see.
You have fives.
Wait, all fives have a red version two for more points.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, we got another 8.
But, um, we don't need it then, right?
So, beginner game.
Yeah, who has the East?
Give me the other Easts.
So, I think I had the 8 before.
Oh!
So, I should pawn here.
I should pawn for the East.
right pawn I pawn I pawn for oh and I discard maybe the two
the two pin yes okay I knew okay Oh wait uh-oh
this one I need the two is that what it's showing that's
what oh my god no you
guys the AI the AI bested me the AI best we started with us
such a good hand too and the AI bested me
it's even stop saying AI easy it's making me so sad The AI
is sentient.
You're good, you didn't feed.
Itihime experience.
No, I did get second though, I did get second.
I didn't lose entirely.
Let's try...
I mean, just like with my gotcha.
The AIs have gotten crazier, to be honest.
I believe you, Tye.
It's just like with my gotcha.
entirely I still got someone let me see something real quick
with my bank I had to make some I had to buy some plane
tickets recently so I just want to check how my bank how my
card looks right now let's see mmm mmm shits
I bought with my with my miles and let's see I have enough
points hold on I can redeem these points on my card redeem
you guys you guys getting a travel card is so awesome
um actually I'll do this later my oh she's gonna starve
No money for travel.
Miles for gotcha.
I don't know when we get the Patreon money.
I don't know, actually, when that happens.
Looking good with them glasses.
Very cute.
Oh, really?
Do you like the glasses?
I don't really like this style, though.
Maybe like around glasses.
I'm so proud of you, Minda.
I was so happy to see the whole...
HENYA collab!
You're so cute!
I'm so glad to see you happy!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Patreon is first of the month.
Wow, okay.
Big round glasses with a swirly pattern on the lens.
Hey, that's really nerd, then.
That's really nerdy glasses, then.
Yeah, I'm so glad that I could collab with HENYA 2.
I actually have been thinking so much about Hell Divers.
It was a lot of fun, so...
It was so much fun.
Okay, just...
This is a little bit more.
Just like...
I'll do two more, two more, two more, two more, two more,
two more.
Not tumor, two more.
Wait, how much do I have to get?
18 wait 18 18 18
maybe if I do like that
that's 24 how much do I need 30 3600
I could just do these two and then it'll be fine
Yeah, 36.
By the way, Oshi Fun.
No!
Thank you, though.
Thank you.
But, I'll do these two.
I'm not going for the pity.
But I'm really...
I am...
I've been wanting to learn...
Oh my goodness.
I've been wanting to learn Majong for so long.
I'm serious.
I want to have characters that I like to play with.
Characters that I like.
To go with, you know what I mean?
Hey.
What character do I want?
I want Shiroko!
I want Shiroko.
Okay, this one, I'm getting the other one.
And then that's it.
That's it.
I'm not crazy.
Something, something.
On stream content, something, something.
Kayoko, please.
She's not in the game!
It's only Aru, Mutsuki, Shiroko, and Hoshino.
I have a poll and another gotcha later.
Please soak my common polls.
for you, Daniel.
Summon.
Shiroko.
No, I don't really want Shiroko that much.
You know what?
I don't really... I don't really care.
You know...
Whatever.
I feel like I've learned so much this stream, though.
Truly, truly.
Thank you guys so much for helping me out.
Mint, do you play Blue Archive every day?
I play Blue Archive every day.
would be a shame if you got hoshino no way you'll get her
surely not i don't want hoshino i don't want aru i don't
want shiroko i don't want any i gotta
dream the other night where you turn into a fruit
fortunately it was just a figment of my imagination
What a cat paw!
I got more shit'em.
That's actually my whole poll is a shit'em.
Thank you, game.
We got the cat paw though.
I am excited about that.
Alexa play unravel.
Oh no, something, something.
Did I get it?
Heart of the ocean?
Oh, my gosh.
It's so funny, too, because recently I was just like, man, I
really want to cosplay Hoshino.
This is so perfect!
Who sent that earlier?
That's super chat.
Where are you?
You...
It was me!
Grump!
Grump, you did it!
You saved my poll!
You saved it!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the thank you.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, Grumpy, we're in my lucky time!
You really did it, you manifested it.
Now single poles?
Oh, I do have enough for single poles, don't I?
I always forget that's an option.
It's always go big or go home, you know?
We do have a couple, though.
Go to shirt icon.
Oh, that's where we can buy the other things, right?
The other skins.
Oh, there's more!
The bond!
Gift.
What's a good one?
So if I do like this one...
She's sleeping on a whale.
Beeching.
So cute.
I like the way.
Oh.
It's more.
I like the way.
I'm Abidos, Koto School School.
I've noticed that I came here, but...
Well, I can just do it.
No.
She's so cute.
It's so cute.
She's such an Oji-san.
Oh, you look good.
This is...
Robbing a kan?
Under the sea.
Under the river.
What are all of...
There's so many lines.
PewTuber owned a whole stock.
I lucksacked Mutski the other day.
Hope you get everyone you want from this banner.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for this.
Very, very spooky.
Akadono.
Thank you.
Quadruple floors.
So spooky, spooky, spooky.
Oh my gosh, look how many there...
My brain is starting...
Wait, Bai Man?
San Bai Man?
Honey Man Man Gan?
What is going on?
There's so much!
There's so...
Holy cow!
How many voice lines are there?
Check the Yaku list, please?
How do I find that?
Look at that!
So cute!
So cute, so cute!
Me too.
Hold on, throw this over here real quick.
How tall is...
How tall is Hoshi here?
Oh, I...
I'm too tall right now.
How tall is she?
Bring back the glasses.
Hold on.
Almost the same high.
145.
Oh, I'm a little taller.
So this should be kind of accurate, right?
Wait, wait, hold on.
How do I do it?
Hold on.
How do I?
There's like a way that I can move my legs.
Oh.
Oh, no, I made myself smaller.
Too small.
Like here, right?
Chicken wing arms?
What are you talking about?
I can jump you guys, did you know that?
Boink!
Hooray!
I
think that's because I'm a ghost, you guys.
Here, let's do one arm up, one arm down, though.
Kind of like...
Wait, I want to be opposite of her.
Cheese!
Wait, I have to be kind of a sleepy face too.
What was that?
Oh, no, not the sticky keys.
That scared me.
Thank you!
Jump, ghost girl.
Jump!
Jump like your life defends on it!
Give me ten more jumping jacks!
Yes, sir!
Wait.
Oh!
Yes, sir!
One, two, three, four!
She's doing it, she's doing it.
Oh, wait, I can beat, hold on.
You know what I'm gonna beat?
I'm gonna be the spooky ghost haunting.
Oh, Shino.
Why is my gacha look so bad?
I wanted Shiroko.
I even wore her halo.
Oh, she know.
Ooh.
You killed her.
Nope.
I didn't kill anybody.
They're in my leg, you sticking out.
Ta-da.
Ta-da-da.
Now we're Facing the same way.
Yeah.
Well, you do have her Halo, so she might be dead.
No.
She's literally sleeping.
How do I go back?
Meow.
There we go.
That was fun.
Little photo shoot time, right?
Little photo shoot time.
sleeping forever why is your sleeve on hoshino's chest what
chest um her chest yeah yeah wait what if I save changes oh
it moves her to the middle oh that's so cute actually wait
so I can like move her around however I want so I can if I'm
like oh yeah hoshino She knows legs.
Whoa, pero, pero, pero.
Click the question mark.
Ah, here we go.
Yeah, someone asked me about the looking at the Yakus
earlier.
All symbols, fully concealed hand, man, men, men, men, men
only.
Win a hand by sumo.
Drawing the winning tile at...
Men's engine closed hand.
Seat wind.
Oh my gosh.
Oh!
1-2-3-2-3-4, 3-4-5, 6-6-6, 9-9?
This looks impossible.
A full flush.
Holy cow.
This seems like something I'm gonna have to really study.
Blessing of heaven, blessing of earth.
Big three dragons.
Wow.
Easier than you think, really?
Four concealed triplets.
What is a men's engine?
Green dragon is not necessary.
Green dragon is necessary in my heart.
A closed hand.
Oh, welcome to my bishop.
Thank you!
Closed hand, no calls.
These were all the ones that, like, had the different voice
lines.
Thank you again for the vibe gifted.
Thank you.
13 orphans is a myth.
What would that be under?
Oh, there it is.
Win a hand with one of each 13 terminal tiles plus any tile
matches one of them.
Wait.
Win a...
Win a hand with one of each 13 terminal tiles.
Oh!
Plus any tile matches one of them.
So it's like opposite.
It's the exact opposite of the...
of the simple one.
Because you have to get...
You can only get one's nines.
And then the...
The...
the honorific ones, right?
What does it mean plus any tile matches one of them?
What does that mean?
It's the pair.
Oh, the nine pair here.
Ah, I see, I see.
Ah, okay, okay.
So, but it's any tile matches one of them.
So if it's like, if I have two, two Wests, it would be fine.
Still any pair of anyone.
Just one pair.
Not all done.
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I learned so much today.
Oh my god.
I feel like I actually learned so, so much.
Like I feel like maybe I couldn't win any game, but I could
at least know a little bit of what I'm doing.
I learned so much.
For real.
I feel like I could...
Now I'm going to watch Saki and I'm going to be like...
in with knowledge that I already know so the power of blue
art it only took blue archive to get me to learn oops I
forgot to change this to get it only took blue archive to
learn me learn for me well learn wait it only took blue
archive for me to learn mahjong a little bit I
do want to watch akagi though
I have a couple friends that are really into Akagi, so...
Thank you!
I think I know a little bit more about Majang now.
Thanks for the stream, by the way, Arona or Plana?
I think Arona.
I think Arona for me.
She's more my type.
She's very, like...
Like, very Rem-esque.
You know, and I love Rem for...
I mean, I love Rem for everything, but, like, her...
Her looks are just so cute.
But I love Plana, too.
Plana would never give blue albums.
It's fun watching you learn my song.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Hoops.
Ah-ha.
Ho-ho-ho.
How do you feel about Shiroko Terror?
I like her, but I like normal Shiroko.
more.
Fresh joke.
Very fresh.
There's Majang in nearly every Yakuza game.
Oh, then I need to study even more for whenever I play, for
whenever I play.
Yakuza.
Arona.
All blues won gold.
Stop showing my actual polls.
Who's Rem?
Have you read volume final?
I have.
Yes, yes.
Will you be streaming your future Blue Archive polls?
Probably not because I play Blue Archive on my actual phone.
I think I would feel a little naked.
I would feel a little too nervous because it's my actual
phone phone, you know?
Like, it's, I don't know.
It would make me feel like, oh my gosh.
What if I accidentally, like, close?
out then you guys can see everything that's on my well not
that I have I don't really have anything on my home screen
that would be bad I have all my gotcha games which are in a
folder called hell hitting Mike Tyson's ass Wow thank you
for the vibe gifted thank you but if I ever get any good
polls of course I'll show you guys or I'll post them on I'll
post them on Twitter or something I only have three games in
hell.
I have Blue Archive, Toho Lost Word, and Yudu Camp.
And then I have my Webtoons.
I can delete this app.
It's a taxi app from when I was in Japan.
I have Meow Tower, which is a no-no-gram app.
And then I have like social stuff, which is like TikTok,
Discord, YouTube.
But my screen is actually quite cute because I have it.
show you guys now because um but i also have like my
location on here like uh um like you know the weather in my
town and the time and everything but i have pictures of like
um of uh like i have arona here maybe i can like screenshot
it hold on let me find something that won't be so if i okay
If I screenshot this and then black out everything.
Okay, hold on.
I'll show you guys.
Actually, I'm just going to delete these apps.
And then I'll show you.
Remove.
Screenshot.
Oh, actually, I'll move the other pictures that I have to,
even though they're on another page.
I, like, really customized my home screen and stuff.
it's like super duper cute.
Chica.
Okay.
Everything should be good.
I'm going to censor out a couple things real quick.
Skip.
Oh, wait.
There we go.
Actually, it's okay.
Because I'm just on Wi-Fi.
Okay.
Let me send this to myself.
How do I send this to my...
Oh, here.
I'm proud of it.
of my home screen.
It's so cute.
Have you played the Toohu rhythm game, Danmako Kagura?
Used to be a mobile game, but now it's a PC.
I haven't actually.
Let me get this.
Close.
Save.
Screenshot.
My screen is so aesthetic.
But I was thinking of changing it recently anyway, So that's
why I'm fine with showing you guys.
So like you can set up, so basically see how I like, there's
the pictures.
I have, I have a, it's like you put it in a note app and
then you can like set the notes as like a picture like on
your screen.
So I like have it all aesthetic and all set up and cute.
It's not usually like set up like this like the the arona
picture is on like the second page of my of my screen but um
it's usually just kind of like this it's so cute right i
think i'm gonna redo it for summer so meow tower is so base
it's so fun i play it every day ko haru love is it a cute
isn't it like the cutest picture ever yeah this is my this
is inspo for you guys make your wallpaper or make your your
uh your thing so cute you use your stylus yeah that's why i
bought those the samsung ultra i use my stylus all the time
especially for nongrams it's perfect for meow tower it's
actually so so perfect i got hooked on meow tower after you
mentioned it on the pod yeah yeah 138 notifications It's
SMH.
I don't know, actually.
Let's see what most of that is from.
Most of it is actually from Line.
Because I follow a bunch of brand accounts online.
So it's just like, oh, this brand, this like, this clothing
brand sent me a thing.
So it's mostly from those.
I cannot live without my stylist.
Me too.
I also use Samsung Note.
Let's see.
I'm going to put this back.
And get my...
But usually at the top I have like a clock.
And then I also have like a clock widget.
And I also have like one that...
What's the word?
Converts the time to Tokyo.
Like one of those.
Actually, where is that?
And I have a...
weather one which I'm setting up again right now this one oh
my
things all messed up now oh well but yeah I love my phone I
wish I could have gotten the blue archive the blue archive
one though I'm so sad about like there was a special edition
blue archive phone that I couldn't get So, I rotate through
wallpapers too.
Too much to keep a unique icon theme.
Really?
I like this one because it's kind of hard to tell.
But, um, down here, the, you see, like, the different pages?
They're actually heart shapes.
And then when I, like, um, my whole thing is, like, all my
texts and everything are, like, um, I don't have anything
that I could, like, I would have to block out, like,
everything if I were to show you my texts.
makes everything hearts and cherries and it's like a purple
gingham theme it's super duper cute
so yeah
the go app is go taxi in japan if you i recommend getting
that if you if you well if you use taxis i only used it a
couple times actually i only i really downloaded it um
because i prefer taking the train because first of all taxis
are so expensive um but uh i used it um i only downloaded it
closer to the end of my trip because i needed to get a taxi
uh to the airport and there were no taxis that would like
come to my apartment so is hell all your gotcha games yeah
Drop the keyboard theme?
It's just normal.
It's like, it's so, it's just normal.
It's relatively easy to get taxis at most train stations,
though.
Yeah, but I wasn't close to a train station.
My apartment was quite far, actually, so.
There was a close-ish train station, but...
Oh my god.
Getting my suitcases down the stairs.
was actual I thought I almost fell down the stairs at one
point I thought I was actually going to pass away a second
time I was like Oh my god I was falling I was falling in
slow motion There's mall things Welcome to membership Thank
you Yeah That was pretty bad
Getting suitcases down to Tokyo subway is an experience I
should have probably just how many times does mint have to
die I probably should have just like kuro neko them to the
to the airport but it's fine can't you just phase your
luggage to the floor I'm a ghost not my luggage not my
luggage
kuro neko it's um it's a a shipping service it's a shipping
service yeah laughs in Danny Phantom yeah you wouldn't
imagine how many things Danny Phantom gets wrong
it's all good I was always too stubborn or cheap to use Kuro
Neko for stuff like that I thought you were talking about
Ore Ivo
took the Johane taxi to the Awashima hotel dock in Numazu
last month after I missed the bus and saw it waiting there
it was a sign you know what that's the most proper time to
use a taxi ever
that's like the most proper time to use a taxi ever
but also I've had to use a taxi when I was out late too much
or I was like it was uh I was out too late at one time and
the trains had stopped so I had to take a taxi home and the
guy the taxi driver was so judgmental because he was like he
was like why did you stay out so late you know how expensive
this taxi is now you could have gotten yourself a good steak
I was like sir I need to go home It's not my fault Bank
account mad at me right now Please Stop donating Yeah But it
was a time I I stayed out for I stayed out because I I went
to see What's it called?
Inautak and Daoko And some other DJs So obviously at DJ
events, I never stayed late for Mogra though.
I always left before the final train when I went to Mogra
though because my apartment was really far from Akiva.
It was so sad because I barely went to Akiva when I last was
in Japan because I was always so far away.
And also, I'm also Oji-san, I can't stay out so late.
I stay, I usually, if I stay out late, it's like the latest
is like 3 a.m.
Which is still pretty late.
I don't like to ruin my sleep schedule so much.
Where I'm like up at first train, you know?
Hmm.
3 a.m.
is pretty late.
It is, but.
But, it's not as bad.
Do better VTuber.
What's that?
We're donating?
No!
And 3 a.m.
is like, is, is like, is like, uh, the latest I'll do, you
know?
Maybe I am Oji-san if 3 a.m.
isn't late.
No, everyone that says 3 a.m.
is late is also Oji-san.
Everyone that says 3 a.m.
some people are naturally night owls I get all my I get all
my work done at night usually you know so it's okay we can
be Oji-san together I'm Oji-san and I'm proud yeah putting
my luck into this PayPal time capsule so Vid can have some
oh why am I so big?
some lucky polls when this Dodo finally reaches her thank
you Gapu I'll use that in blue archive I'll use it in Blue
Archive Thank you I haven't spent so much in Blue Archive
Maybe I've spent less than $100 In Blue Archive for sure You
probably even less than $50 In Blue Archive So Not that much
Not that much Not that much Are you going to be chasing for
the railgun collab?
I don't know I want to I want to Because...
Because she'll never come...
They'll never come back?
But at the same time...
I really want Dress Hina.
So I'm like...
What do I do?
I save for Dress Hina?
Or...
You dare approach me.
Did you get Miku?
No.
I didn't get Miku.
A Mr. Miku.
Some.
Yeah, we'll see.
I got Miku.
She's kind of bad.
Yeah, I know Dressina is permanent.
I don't know.
I feel like when they do limit, like...
Two, thank you.
Would have been set up trains and taxis.
Motorcycle.
Like taking a motorcycle?
I'm even too afraid to ride a bike in Japan I'm not gonna
lie I don't I'm too afraid to ride a bike I'll never drive
anything I will walk everywhere
um but I feel like for characters that are like limited
where they're where they're like they'll never come back
like Miku or the Railgun collab, stuff like that.
I feel like they don't make them very good on purpose
because, like, I don't know.
Because if you get them and you miss out, or rather if you
miss out, like, you would be so sad missing out on such a
good character.
You know what I mean?
And the same mentality until I needed to get a license.
I drive here, but I don't drive.
in Japan.
Black Rock Shooter in PGR is also pretty weak.
What do you mean stinky minto?
But the scenes though, true.
Oh my gosh, did you guys see with the ReZero collab for
Niki?
Okay, when I saw like the previews for it, I was actually
pretty disappointed.
I was like...
Some coin for the rail dress cut button.
Stop it, please.
If you ever feel the need to donate, never donate because of
Gacha.
It makes me feel so dirty.
Um...
But, uh...
I was so disappointed by the...
ReZero because...
Where's the jiggle?
That's all Nike is!
Well, not all, but it's live.
Just no jiggle.
It's so sad.
So disappointing.
But it was cute.
They were very cute.
I heard the Rizero collab was super rushed.
Interesting.
I don't know why it would be, but...
Request of the Rights Holder.
I was thinking that too.
But...
Um...
I was thinking of that too, but...
But it's Nikkei.
It's that kind of game, you know?
Like...
I feel like it's really weird to be like...
Oh, by the way, don't...
Don't make them jiggle, even though that's like...
The appeal of your game.
You know?
I don't know.
I feel like...
ago a vtuber graduated and she mentioned she liked getting
supers from fans talking of their achievements that
motivated me to stick to gym i've lost five kgs since then
because of her let's go oh my gosh chosen that's so awesome
what a coin can you think i also like hearing about your
achievements holy cow big w
Oh my gosh.
Let's go.
What's kilogram in American?
I don't know, actually.
Let's see.
One kilogram is two pounds.
Uh, it's a little over ten pounds.
It's a little over...
Two point five pounds.
to kilogram so yeah 11 11 pounds how much that is that in
hamburgers like wait hold on four quarter pounders four
times 11 44 burgers
That's a lot of meat.
I lost 44 burgers.
Yeah!
44 burgers!
I don't want a burger.
Yummy.
Go to items, gifts, donate gifts to gain star dust.
50 star dust buys one summon to gift from the shop.
I don't think I have enough items, though, right?
Wait.
I also don't want to give away my gifts if I'm going to give
them to if I want to level up Hoshino, right?
Oh, I forgot.
I'm just using, I'm just putting everything that I've
gotten.
You probably have enough for one ticket.
For one, one poll or One poll.
Inoume, please.
You set your bank.
Thank you for the buy-up gift.
Thank you.
One poll, yeah.
Oh, that's not worth it then.
That's not worth it.
You can get free stuff in the VIP tab since you bought Jade.
Oh, really?
VIP.
Where is that?
VF.
Under event?
Jade menu?
Oh yeah, I have to buy these too.
No way.
880!
Oh my gosh.
It's $15 per outfit.
It hurts.
It hurts so bad.
Chances to change failures to success.
Yay!
I still don't see the VIP tag though.
We are number one.
I kind of, I miss, I really enjoy, I miss that like time on
the internet when everyone was just collectively making we
are number one mashups.
Everybody unified for that song.
Everyone unified for that guy, you know?
Jade buying menu VIP time.
Did I miss it?
this is just the shop so okay so i have to go here ah here
we go here we go claim i claimed some things i don't know
what these are though
yeah stiff and carl that guy was so awesome yeah rip to a
legend i know everyone like came together because of him and
oh wait there's more claim successfully claim Claim.
Claim.
Whoa.
We got so much.
Oh, this is so cute.
He was also super cool about it and clearly loved all the
memes too.
Meow.
You can use that dust to buy gacha tickets.
What's the dust?
This?
No, these are... Oh, this dust!
Star dust!
Is there like a transfer?
Like a...
Star dust to Jade?
100 star dust equals two rolls.
Really?
Go to the shop.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Hand holding for the win.
Hand hold me.
Fortune tab.
Oh!
Here we go.
And I have...
How many do I have?
What's a rename scroll?
You may change your nickname and...
Oh.
What?
Why does it cost actual money to change my name?
Oh, I have a hundred.
Okay!
No way.
That's so expensive even.
Yo Star, why?
I
don't have enough.
Okay, let's do this one then.
Why not?
What's this one do anyway?
One random green gift.
One random purple gift.
You know what, whatever.
Well, I couldn't summon once.
Tap.
I think they gave me a chance.
We have one rename ticket out for free at some point.
That's crazy!
Only one!
Okay, re-summon.
This is the one.
Okay.
What if you, um, what happens if you get a dupe?
You still have three single pulls.
I'm thinking I'm using them because if I buy, let's see.
wait if i get wait 480
this one would be close right wait 480 hold on the blue
donuts
it's so it's oh it's a little off yeah we'll just do the
solo or we'll just do the though some let's do it we have a
couple Girl,
diamond.
One, two more.
I really like the art style of Blue Archive in Majang Soul,
but I think I'll pass.
Trying to rehabilitate from Gacha.
Only Blue Archive currently.
You know what?
That's basically me, Haido.
I only have one Gacha that I like actually...
Like, try.
Even in this game...
Even in this game, like, the gotcha feels...
Maybe it's more expensive because, like...
In this, you really don't have to do the gotcha.
You know what I mean?
Like, in other games, you get gotcha...
You get other characters for, like, special abilities.
But in this game, it's, like, just cosmetic.
So maybe that's why it's, like, kind of more expensive,
right?
I want to head pat Hoshi no.
So, I kind of understand it.
Like in other games, it's like, you know, you get characters
to get to do better damage and do stuff like that.
But here it is just mahjong.
You can totally play without paying anything.
So, I mean, not to say that you have to pay for other, like,
you know, other gotcha games too.
But I get it, I get it.
A little bit.
okay there's one really funny thing about hoshino it is her
recollection if you look up hoshino's recollection charlie
thank you for the five gifted thank you thank you so much if
you look up hoshino's recollection in blue archive oh my god
her face is so dumb it's so it's so silly goes to she goes
to the aquarium and like it's the live 2d where her eyes are
just like bugging out of her head she and she goes like like
her eyes are literally like bugging out it's so funny let me
see if I can find a picture let's see
Oh no, wait, there's none that shows her buggy eyes.
Boo, I'm back!
Welcome back!
Woohoo!
Supachari!
I wonder if there's like a gift of it.
No.
It's just her standing there.
I need the movement.
I need the hua!
There are videos on YouTube?
Yeah.
Let me turn off the audio real quick because I don't want it
to play.
I don't want to get copyright struck by anybody.
Let's see.
Okay.
There we go.
Head pat, hooshino.
Head pat hooshino.
When did she do that?
Oh, there it is.
Oh,
my God.
It's so funny.
It's the movement, too, with it.
It's just her eyes are buggy so much.
Wee.
It's so funny.
I like seeing it every time.
It makes me laugh every time.
Some of you have been asking for way three.
Oh my god.
It's like, oh god, it's so scary.
Every time I blink...
There we go.
It's just a little bit wobbly.
Thank you guys again for teaching me how to play Mahjong a
little bit at least.
I will keep practicing.
I will keep playing.
And one day I would like to do some sort of tournament.
I don't know.
Maybe it's a lot of pressure though.
Maybe I'll just play for fun.
Who knows.
But...
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go uh and let my brain rest for a
little while so say it sensei a to you thank you
so much thank you thank you thank you we'll see you guys um
uh tomorrow for our tour of I'm so excited, I'm so excited
to go around Akima, so yeah!
Thank you for the stream, later man, thank you guys, thank
you, thank you!
Otsuminto!
Bye bye!
Bye bye bye bye!
See you later!
See you!
Thank you guys!
Bye bye!
I saved my notes so I have them.
I saved my notes.
So I will be prepared.
I will study the books.
I will study the tide.
I am ready.
Oh, to minto.
Look at me kicking my little feet.
This is so cute!
I should get an updated one.
Like of, I mean, of my new outfit.
My current outfit.
I hope that I've been using.
Have a good night.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you!
What is the name for simpler times?
Times that are simple.
Thanks.
Did you kick him as a dors?
Yeah.
I like this one a lot though.
I don't know if this artist, this was actually like your
character here thing.
So the artist like had a template and I just like, I was
like, oh my gosh, this is perfect.
It was during Halloween.
So I got it and it's just so cute.
five stimes.
Stimes gate.
Times to simp?
No!
No.
Hi.
Oh, it's your main choice.
Well, you do love Halloween so it fits.
I love Halloween.
I'm a spooky ghost.
My birthday is the start of Halloween.
Oh, sorry.
Boom.
Bye-bye.
I want to have a little